c'est dommage parce que sinon Thierry
c'est formidable il y a du mouvement du
rythme et la fin c'est un crève-cœur
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
[Musique]
bien on commence avec l'enquête de la
semaine qui a volé l'esquimau de Nicolas
Sarkozy
jeudi c'était la Saint-Nicolas avant
c'est pas tous les jours la
Saint-Nicolas
[Applaudissements]
Ségolène Royal sur la scène du Théâtre
du Rond-Point alors c'est un one man
show super drôle il y a de l'émotion une
rupture un coach avec un cheveu sur la
langue qui donne des conseils vas-y
c'est got et divines et il y a une fin à
la con alors que ça marche la salle est
acquise elle propose un rôle un grand
nier qui collectionne les tracteurs
[Applaudissements]
c'est dommage c'est dommage parce que
sinon Thierry ça chauffe formidable il y
a du mouvement du rythme et la fin c'est
un crève-cœur
[Applaudissements]
international pour libérer Ingrid
Bettencourt Sarkozy discute avec les
phares on espère que ça va marcher sinon
Renault va faire un nouvel album
[Musique]
Birmanie les claquettes portées par les
moines sont responsables des massacres
bah oui vous avez déjà essayé de courir
en claquettes
le sort des homosexuels chinois
familiorent ils font partie intégrante
de la délégation officielle des JO 2008
[Musique]
le coup de fil de l'Elysée aboutine
déchaîne la polémique
de félicitations là j'ai le texte bravo
pour les 200.000 morts en Tchétchénie et
pour ta recette du cocktail au Pologne
j'espère que tu vas réussir à éliminer
Kasparov bien à toi Nicolas quitten
[Applaudissements]
c'est sympa
deux bergers allemands chargés de la
lutte antidrogue ont été décorées oui il
faut que nos amis chiens comprennent
Patrick Poivre d'Arvor que désormais aux
récompensera le mérite un chien qui
trouve de la drogue ce sera une médaille
en revanche un chien qui bouffe un
nourrisson ce sera le tanaisie
[Applaudissements]
27e balle des débutants de toutes les
princesses sont trouvées un partenaire
sauf la grande du milieu qui une fois de
plus est rentré bredouille
[Applaudissements]
télévision le courage de TF1 alors que
la chaîne passe sous la barre des 30%,
elle engage Lorie comme comédienne c'est
une stratégie toucher le fond pour
pouvoir remonter
[Applaudissements]
et puis la réplique cinglante de TF1 au
time qui s'interroge sur la mort de la
culture française Cauet tous les jours à
l'écran des janvier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Geneviève de Fontenay voudrait mourir
sur scène inquiétude c'est la troisième
menace émanant du monde du showbiz je
rappelle les deux premières Dorothée je
suis prête pour une nouvelle carrière
Michel Drucker je ne prendrai jamais ma
retraite
plus d'otages
et on termine avec une étude de 96% des
Français jugent la fessée normale pour
les adeptes au ministère de la Justice
Rachida vous accueille derrière le
sourire une poigne de fer écrit match
barrésie et talons aiguille si vous êtes
très très très vilain au ministère de
l'Intérieur si vous êtes gérontophile
MAM c'est son nom de code vous fessera
un gouvernement très hot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà je vous l'ai dit au début de cette
chronique Patrick Poivre d'Arvor
désormais les filles qui travaillent
avec moi récompenseront le mérite à la
semaine prochaine merci et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de Inna larditube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu